I do find it distressing though that the
gay community and I and I have gay
friends who hate me even using that term
that the gay community they really
resent it but there is a gay community I
live in West Hollywood I see it on the
boulevard all the time but I think the
problem is that that is happening
everywhere and I do think that I would
love it if the gay community listed more
to someone like Morrissey who is
constantly criticized by the gay
community for just being open and honest
and saying what he feels I don't think
he's attacking anybody he's just he's
not really on the right side of the
political curve for most gay people and
I and he is automatically attacked now
that is really true for a lot of people
I wish that was pulled back you on all
this is shaped by being a bad gay that
gays are sort of outsiders off the bat
and that does a frame how you kind of
look at the world a little bit
completely yeah well look it's what I
think made me want to be a writer in
many ways I think being gay as a kid
then I'm not so sure now I think it's
probably a lot easier and you're a lot
more what's the word acclimated into
culture in a way at a much earlier age
than we ever were I'm a bit older than
you but growing up in the 70s and into
the 80s you were kind of a secret agent
yeah you were secret a 90s you were not
out and you had to kind of navigate
these paths on your own one of the
things that I think is really
interesting about being gay is that you
have to I think you look at the world
and a much more realistic hard way than
your straight counterpoints - I think
that you see the world for what it's
really like you're not really involved
in the poses and in the game and ship
that goes on within you know societal
structures and you also have to you know
redefine most everything that you
experience culturally whether it's
movies whether it's pop songs whether
it's things you watch on TV whether it's
books you read so you really begin to
you
to see the world in a way that none of
your other friends do you are an
outsider you are an outsider because of
that but I also have to say that I did
not let it define me and it was not
something that ever got me down I never
got depressed by it it was something
that I realized was just another thing I
had to deal with I'm on many other
things I had to deal with it was not of
and I think this is probably where I was
not that concerned with it and it became
something that was you know I resented
the fact that I couldn't express myself
in a certain way and I think that
frustration certainly played a part in
wanting to become a writer so I have to
say you know thank you it away I mean it
kind of worked for me oh yeah but when
you see what sort of has happened to the
gay community where it used to maybe in
the 70s and 80s and before that there
was a subversive nature to it a lot of
good art and music and underground
scenes all writing and writing and all
sorts of things came from it where now
it seems like it's so the reverse it's
the most sort of woke you sort of
cemented bland bland way of thinking
well in terms of mainstream you know
whatever the hell that is but I have to
say that's true of everything and it's
just that what happened last 10 years is
that gay life whatever that means and I
do believe that there is a certain
aspect if you're a gay person that you
do have a bit of a gay life it doesn't
mean that it overwhelms you and
everything becomes gay it means that
yeah sure you have the same
preoccupations and some of the same
concerns as fellow gay people you
obviously have to in terms of 20 years
ago politics or even further back than
that how the United States was dealing
with the AIDS crisis for example so you
you are you are pushed together to a
degree but I I think that that's
happening all over the place I do find
it distressing though that the gay
community and I and I have gay friends
who hate me even using that term that
the gay community they really resent it
but there is a gay community I live in
West Hollywood I see it on the boulevard
all the time but I think the problem is
that that is happening everywhere and I
do think
that I would love it if the gay
community listed more to someone like
Morrissey who was constantly criticized
by the gay community for just being open
and honest and saying what he feels I
don't think he's attacking anybody he's
just he's not really on the right side
of the political curve for most gay
people and I and he's automatically
attacked now that is really true for a
lot of people I wish that was pulled
back and I wish that the conversation
was once we're open it just isn't right
now and that is that is a problem but
it's not just affecting the gay
community is I think everywhere yeah do
you see that as sort of a direct
offshoot of what identity politics has
done you don't identify enough as gay or
the new thing is that you can be gay so
there's like a like a Peter teal peep-bo
dodge edge maybe the way we are a little
bit version of gay but we're not queer
sort of right like we don't prescribe to
the whole set of ideas it's not enough
to be an out gay person living in West
Hollywood right you know from LA for you
know 50 years that's that that then
quite get it but yeah yeah but you have
to understand I kind of made my way
through that in the 80s as a young
writer and I knew I was in what I call
the glass closet meaning everyone I knew
knew I was gay and I had a partner when
I talk to the media I count [ __ ] in the
back in those days basically if you came
out and you were a gay writer you were
get a wise degree you were put into the
gay section of bookstores I don't think
they have those anymore I'm not sure if
they do but they did have an and it
meant a kind of death in a way for for
for a mainstream acceptance right so
even if you weren't writing about gay
things specifically what sort of you
were gay so uh right look I was on the
gay channel on Sirius XM it was
ridiculous I didn't want to be on the
gay Channel I wanted to be on any of the
politics channels I write them put me on
the left channel put me on the right
channel the other channel anything but
they were like well you're gay right
what do we do at the game wait exactly
which is the problem and that is what I
always resisted because I knew I was so
much more than simply gay
or we're who I wanted to have sex with I
always knew that from a very early age
that I was a writer that I was a person
that I liked movies that I all these
things that I wanted to do and then the
gay somewhere over here and I never felt
the need to make that the number one
aspect of my identity I don't even think
I could even came out to anybody it just
sort of happened gradually
oh you're bringing Jim to the party or
Oh Jim's coming for the weekend or
whatever and that was how it was I
really didn't think that anyone kind of
what I deserve a tearful coming out for
me and I never even felt that but now
that's not to say that people needed to
go through that narrative and that's and
that's fine but I just didn't tie myself
into with a gay identity and so I do
think that that is a problem but again
not just don't know just for gay people
but for people of color for women it
really had but I also believe Dave that
this is an online problem in a way there
is an offline world out there
an office that thing still exists which
are we right now
well we're I think we're having
conversation yeah yeah I hope I live my
entire life offline to a degree even
even when I'm online and I had them that
I'm not into a lot of trouble over the
past decade or so but I think there's an
offline world and I am I'm part of it
and I know that the way women and men
and gay people express themselves are
very different and how they express
themselves online and that is kind of
where we're at right now and I think a
lot of people are too afraid to say
things that they say offline online and
we'll just see where this no plays
itself out so it's funny you bring that
up because I was gonna mention a little
bit later so this is jumping ahead that
American Psycho it's almost to me which
it was your third novel right it was the
third Melville um that it's like we're
all sort of behaving like American
Psycho you know like we're all sort of
the same in the functional world in the
real world right and then everyone with
their secret avatars and their anonymous
accounts or whatever is a psychopath
online so like it's maybe maybe there's
your sequel or something well that's
really interesting I mean I I talked a
lot about the creation of American
Psycho in the book white and for some
reason it haunted me because it was
something that I really thought was
going to be the strange experimental
novel that maybe 3000 people read I
thought it was so weird so out there so
super violent and porn
I think that whatever funny cuz it cost
you some we can get to the misogynistic
I'm not saying that I'm saying with
criticism yeah misogyny just because
there's acts of misogyny doesn't mean
the book is misogynist of course so so I
really didn't think that many people
were gonna read it but I also think that
one of the reasons why it still look
popular today and still in print and
tons of people read the book a lot of it
has to do with the movie the movie
definitely made people re-enter ested in
the book was because Patrick Bateman is
kind of a curator of his life in a way
it's very much the way people are now I
mean a lot of Americans like it was
almost as if Patrick Bateman is showing
you a series of selfies on his Instagram
he's constantly described in his life
and what he's wearing and what he's
eating and where he's going and what
restaurant is that ad and what ditches
he's eating in the restaurant it
basically is how people treat their
lives today from this kind of like
almost God's eye view of you know not
living or participating in it but
actually just like photographing it if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell